The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIC GRIMSON: OK,
welcome back or welcome,
depending on whether
you've been away or not.
I'm going to start with
two simple announcements.
There is a reading
assignment for this lecture,
actually for the next two
lectures, which is chapter 18.
And on a much
happier note, there
is no lecture
Wednesday because we
hope that you're
going to be busy
preparing to get that
tryptophan poisoning
as you eat way too much
turkey and you fall asleep.
More importantly,
I hope you have
a great break over Thanksgiving,
whether you're here
or you're back home
or wherever you are.
But no lecture Wednesday.
Topic for today, I'm going
to start with seems like--
sorry, what's going to seem
like a really obvious statement.
We're living in a
data intensive world.
Whether you're a scientist,
an engineer, social scientist,
financial worker, politician,
manager of a sports team,
you're spending
increasingly larger amounts
of time dealing with data.
And if you're in one
of those positions,
that often means that
you're either writing code
or you're hiring somebody
to write code for you
to figure out that data.
And this section
of the course is
focusing on exactly that issue.
We want to help
you understand what
you can try to do with software
that manipulates data, how you
can write code that would
do that manipulation of data
for you, and especially what
you should believe about what
that software tells you about
data, because sometimes it
tells you stuff that isn't
exactly what you need to know.
And today we're
going to start that
by looking at particularly
the case where we get data
from experiments.
So think of this
lecture and the next one
as sort of being statistics
meets experimental science.
So what do I mean by that?
Imagine you're doing a physics
lab, biology lab, a chemistry
lab, or even something in
sociology or anthropology,
you conduct an experiment
to gather some data.
It could be
measurements in a lab.
It could be answers
on a questionnaire.
You get a set of data.
Once you've got
the data, you want
to think about what
can I do with it,
and that usually will involve
using some model, some theory
about the underlying process
to generate questions
about the data.
What does this data and the
model associated with it
tell me about
future expectations,
help me predict
other results that
will come out of this data.
In the social case,
it could be how
do I think about
how people are going
to respond to a
poll about who are
you voting for in the next
election, for example.
Given the data, given the
model, the third thing
we're typically
going to want to do
is then design a computation
to help us answer questions
about the data, run a
computational experiment
to complement the
physical experiment
or the social experiment
we used to gather
the data in the first place.
And that computation
could be something deep.
It could be something a
little more interesting,
depending on how you're
thinking about it.
But we want to think
about how do we
use computation to run
additional experiments for us.
So I'm going to start by
using an example of gathering
experimental data,
and I want to start
with the idea of a spring.
How would I model a spring?
How would I gather
data about a spring?
And how would I write software
to help me answer questions
about a spring?
So what's spring?
Well, there's one kind of
spring, a little hard to model,
although it could be interesting
what's swimming around in there
and how do I think about
the ecological implications
of that spring.
Here's a second kind of spring.
It's about four or
five months away,
but eventually we'll
get through this winter
and get to that spring
and that would be nice,
but I'm not going to
model that one either.
And yes, my jokes
are really bad,
and yes, you can't do
a darn thing about them
because I am tenured because--
while I'd like to model
these two springs,
we're going to
stick with the one
that you see in physics
labs, these kinds of springs,
so-called linear springs.
And these are springs that
have the property that you
can stretch or compress them
by applying a force to it.
And when you release
them, they literally
spring back to the position
they were originally.
So we're going to deal with
these kinds of springs.
And the distinguishing
characteristics
of these two springs
and others in this class
is that that force you require
to compress it or stretch
it a certain amount--
the amount of force you
require varies linearly
in the distance.
So if it takes some
amount of force
to compress it some
amount of distance,
it takes twice as much force
to compress it twice as much
of a distance.
It's linearly related.
So each one of these springs--
these kinds of springs
has that property.
The amount of force
needed to stretch
or compress it's linear
in that distance.
Associated with
these springs there
is something called
a spring constant--
usually represented
by the number k--
that determines
how much force do
you need to stretch or
compress the spring.
Now, it turns out that that
spring constant can vary a lot.
The slinky actually has a
very low spring constant.
It's one newton per meter.
That spring on the
suspension of a motorcycle
has a much bigger
spring constant.
It's a lot stiffer,
35,000 newtons per meter.
And just in case
you don't remember,
a newton is the
amount of force you
need to accelerate a
one-kilogram mass one
meter per second squared.
We'll come back to
that in a second.
But the idea is we'd like
to think about how do we
model these kinds of springs.
Well, turns out,
fortunately for us,
that that was done
about 300-plus years ago
by a British physicist
named Robert Hooke.
Back in 1676 he formulated
Hooke's law of elasticity.
Simple expression that
says the force you
need to compress
or stretch a spring
is linearly related
to the distance, d,
that you've actually
done that compression in,
or another way of saying
it is, if I compress
a spring some amount, the
force that's stored in it
is linearly related
to that distance.
And the negative sign
here basically says
it's pointing in the
opposite direction.
So if I compress, the force
is going to push it back out.
If I stretch it, the force
is going to push back
into that resting position.
Now, this law holds for
a wide range of springs,
which is kind of nice.
It's going to hold both
in biological systems
as well as in physical systems.
It doesn't hold perfectly.
There's a limit to how
much you can stretch,
in particular, a spring
before the law breaks down,
and maybe you did
this as a kid, right.
If you take a slinky and
pull it too far apart,
it stops working
because you've exceeded
what's called the elastic
limit of the spring.
Similarly, if you
compress it too far,
although I think you have
to compress it a long ways,
it'll stop working as well.
So it doesn't hold
completely, and it also
doesn't hold for all springs.
Only those springs that
satisfy this linear law,
which are a lot of them.
So, for example, it doesn't
apply to rubber bands,
it doesn't apply
to recurved bows.
Those are two examples
of springs that do not
obey this linear relationship.
But nonetheless,
there's Hooke's law.
And one of the things
we can do is say, well,
let's use it to do a little bit
of reasoning about this spring.
So we can ask the
question, how much
does a rider have to weigh to
compress this spring by one
centimeter?
And we've got Hooke's
law, and I also gave you
a little bit of hint here.
So I told you that this
spring has a spring constant
of 35,000 newtons per meter.
So I could just plug this
in, right, one centimeter,
it's 1/100 of a meter times--
so that's the-- there's
the spring constant.
There's the amount we're
going to compress it.
Do a little math, and that
says that the force I need
is 350 newtons.
So what's a newton?
A small town in Massachusetts,
an interesting cookie,
and a force that we
want to think about.
I keep telling you guys,
the jokes are really bad.
So how do I get force?
Well, you know that.
Mass times acceleration,
right, F equals ma.
For acceleration here, I'm going
to make an assumption, which
is that the spring is basically
oriented perpendicular
to the earth, so that
the acceleration is just
the acceleration of
gravity, which is roughly
9.8 meters per second squared.
It's basically pulling it down.
So I could plug that
back in because remember
what I want to do is figure
out what's the mass I need.
So for the force, I'm
substituting that in.
I've got that expression,
mass times 9.8 meters divided
by seconds squared
is 350 newtons,
divide through by 9.8 both
sides, do a little bit of math.
And it says that the mass I
need is 350 kilograms divided
by 9.8.
And that k refers to kilograms,
not to the spring constant.
Poor choice of example,
but there I am.
And if I do the math, it
says I need a rider that
weighs 35.68 kilos.
And if you're not big
on the metric system,
it's actually a
fairly light rider.
That's about 79 pounds.
So a 79-pound rider would
compress that spring one
centimeter.
So we can figure out
how to use Hooke's law.
We're thinking about what
we want to do with springs.
That's kind of nice.
How will we actually
get the spring constant?
It's really valuable to know
what the spring constant is.
And just to give
you a sense of that,
it's not just to deal
with things like slinkies.
Atomic force microscopes,
need to know the spring
constants of the
components in order
to calibrate them properly.
The force you need to
deform a strand of DNA
is directly related to
the spring constants
of the biological
structures themselves.
So I'd really like to figure
out how do I get them.
How many of you have done this
experiment in physics and hated
it?
Right.
Well, I don't know if
you hated it or not,
but you've done it, right?
Standard way to do it
is I'd take a spring,
I suspend it from some point.
Let it come to a
resting position.
And then I put a mass on
the bottom of the spring.
It kind of bounces around.
And when it settles,
I measure the distance
from where it was
before I put the mass
on to the distance of where it
is after I've added the mass.
I measure that distance.
And then I just plug in.
I plug into that formula there.
The force is minus k times d.
So k the spring constant is the
force, forget the minus sign,
divided by the distance,
and the force here
would be 9.8 meters per
second squared or-- kilograms
per second squared times
the mass divided by d.
So I could just plug it in.
In an ideal world, I'd plug it
in, I'm done, one measurement.
Not so much, right.
Masses aren't always
perfectly calibrated.
Maybe the spring has got
not perfect materials in it.
So ideally I'd actually
do multiple trials.
I would take different weights,
put them on the spring,
make the measurements,
and just record those.
So that's what I'm going to do,
and I've actually done that.
I'm not going to make you do it.
But I get out a set
of measurements.
What have I done here?
I've used different masses,
all increasing by now 0.05
kilograms, and I've
measured the distance
that the spring has deformed.
And ideally, these
would all have
that nice linear relationship,
so I could just plug them in
and I could figure out what
the spring constant is.
So let's take this
data and let's plot it.
And by the way,
all the code you'll
be able to see when
you download the file,
I'm going to walk through
some of it quickly.
This is a simple
way to deal with it,
and I'm going to
back up for a second.
There's my data, and I
actually have done this
in some ways the wrong order.
These are my independent
measures, different masses.
I'm going to plot
those along the x-axis,
the horizontal axis.
These are the dependent things.
These are the things
I'm measuring.
I'm going to plot
those along the y-axis.
So I really should have put
them in the other order.
So just cross your eyes and
make this column go over
to that column, and
we'll be in good shape.
Let's plot this.
So here's a little file.
Having stored those
away in a file,
I'm just going to read
them in, get data.
Just going to do the obvious
thing of read in these things
and return two tuples or
lists, one for the x values--
or if you like, again
going back to it,
this set of values, and
one for the y values.
Now I'm going to
play a little trick
that you may have seen before
that's going to be handy to me.
I'm going to actually
call this function out
of the PyLab library
called array.
I pass in that
tuple, and what it
does is it converts it
into an array, which
is a data structure that has
a fixed number of slots in it
but has a really nice property
I want to take advantage of.
I could do all of
this with lists.
But by converting
that into array
and then giving it the same
name xVals and similarly
for the yVals, I can
now do math on the array
without having to write loops.
And in particular right
here, notice what I'm doing.
I'm taking xVals, which is
an array, multiplying it
by a number.
And what that does is it takes
every entry in the array,
multiplies that
entry, and puts it
into basically a new version
of the array, which I then
store into xVals.
If you've programmed
in Matlab, this
is the same kind
of feeling, right.
I can take an array,
do something to it,
and that's really nice.
So I'm going to scale
all of my values,
and then I'm going to plot them
out some appropriate things.
And if I do it, I get that.
I thought we said Hooke's law
was a linear relationship.
So in an ideal world,
all of these points
ought to lay along
a line somewhere,
where the slope
of the line would
tell me the spring constant.
Not so good, right.
And in fact, if you look
at it, you can kind of
see-- in here you can kind of
imagine there's a line there,
something funky is
going on up here.
And we're going to come back to
that at the end of the lecture.
But how do we think about
actually finding the line?
Well, we know there's
noise in the measurement,
so our best thing to
do is to say, well,
could we just fit a
line to this data?
And how would we do that?
And that's the first big
thing we want to do today.
We want to try and
figure out, given
that we've got
measurement noise, how
do we fit a line to it.
So how do we fit
a curve to data?
Well, what we're basically
going to try and do
is find a way to relate an
independent variable, which
were the masses, the y values,
to the dependent-- sorry,
wrong way.
The independent values,
which are the x-axis,
to the dependent value, what is
the actual displacement we're
going to see?
So another way of saying
it is if I go back to here,
I want to know for
every point along here,
how do I fit something that
predicts what the y value is?
So I need to figure
out how to do that fit.
To decide-- even if I had
a curve, a line that I
thought was a good
fit to that, I
need to decide how good it is.
So imagine I was lucky
and somebody said,
here's a line that
I think describes
Hooke's law in this case.
Great.
I could draw the
line on that data.
I could draw it on this
chunk of data here.
I still need to decide how
do I know if it's a good fit.
And for that, we need something
we call an objective function,
and it's going to
measure how close is
the line to the data to
which I'm trying to fit it.
Once we've defined the objective
function, then what we say
is, OK, now let's find the
line that minimizes it,
the best possible line, the
line that makes that objective
function as small as
possible, because that's going
to be the best fit to the data.
And so that's what
I'd like to do.
We're going to see--
we're going to do it
for general curves,
but we're going to
start just with lines,
with linear function.
So in this case, we
want to say what's
the line such that some
function of the sum
of the distances from the
line to the measured points
is minimized.
And I'm going to come
back in a second to how
do we find the line.
But first we've got to
think about what does it
mean to measure it.
So I've got a point.
Imagine I got a
line that I think
is a good match for the
thing fitting the data.
How do I measure distance?
Well, there's one option.
I could measure just the
displacement along the x-axis.
There's a second option.
I could measure the
displacement vertically.
Or a third option is I could
actually measure the distance
to the closest point
on the line, which
would be that perpendicular
distance there.
You're way too quiet,
which is always dangerous.
What do you think?
I'm going to look for
a show of hands here.
How many people think we
should use x as the thing
that we measure here?
Hands up.
Please don't use a single finger
when you put your hand up.
All right.
Good.
How many people think we
should use p, the perpendicular
distance?
Reasonable number of hands.
And how about y?
And I see actually about
split between p and y.
And that's actually really good.
X doesn't make a
lot of sense, right,
because I know that my
values along the x-axis
are independent measurements.
So the displacement
in that direction
doesn't make a lot of sense.
P makes a lot of sense,
but unfortunately isn't
what I want.
We're going to
see examples later
on where, in fact,
minimizing things
where you minimize that distance
is the right thing to do.
When we do machine
learning, that
is how you find what's called
a classifier or a separator.
But actually here
we're going to pick y,
and the reason is important.
I'm trying to predict the
dependent value, which
is the y value, given an
independent new x value.
And so the displacement,
the uncertainty
is, in fact, the
vertical displacement.
And so I'm going to use y.
That displacement is
the thing I'm going
to measure as the distance.
How do I find this?
I need an objective
function that's
going to tell me what is
the closeness of the fit.
So here's how I'm
going to do it.
I'm going to have some
set of observed values.
Think of it as an array.
I've got some index into
them, so the indices
are giving me the x values.
And the observed values are the
things I've actually measured.
If you want to think
of it this way,
I'm going to go back to
this slide really quickly.
The observed values
are the displacements
or the values along the y-axis.
Sorry about that.
Let's assume that I have
some hypothesized line that I
think fits this data,
y equals ax plus b.
I know the a and the b.
I've hypothesized it.
Then predicted will basically
say given the x value,
the line predicts here's
what the y value should be.
And so I'm going to take the
difference between those two
and square them.
So the difference makes sense.
It tells me how far away is
the observed value from what
the line predicts it should be.
Why am I squaring it?
Well, there are two reasons.
The first one is
that squaring is
going to get rid of the sign.
It shouldn't matter
if my observed value
is some amount above
the predicted value
or some amount below--
the same amount
below the predicted value.
The displacement in
direction shouldn't matter.
It's how far away is it.
Now, you could say, well, why
not just use absolute value?
And the answer is
you could, but we're
going to see in a couple of
slides that by using the square
we get a really nice
property that helps
us find the best fitting line.
So my objective function
here basically says,
given a bunch of
observed values,
use the hypothesized line to
predict what the value should
be, measure the difference
in the y direction--
which is what I'm doing
because I'm measuring predicted
and observed y values--
square them, sum them all up.
It's called least squares.
That's going to give
me a measure of how
close that line is to a fit.
In a second, I'll get to
how you find the best line.
But this hopefully
looks familiar.
Anybody recognize this?
You've seen it
earlier in this class.
Boy, that's a terrible thing
to ask because you don't even
remember the last thing
you did in this class other
than the problem set.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIC GRIMSON: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Variance.
ERIC GRIMSON: Variance.
Thank you.
Absolutely.
Sorry, I didn't bring
any candy today.
That's Professor Guttag.
I got a better arm than
he does, but I still
didn't bring any candy today.
Yeah, it's variance, not quite.
It's almost variance.
That's the variance times
the number of observations,
or another way of saying
it is if I divided this
by the number of observations,
that would be the variance.
If I took the square
root, it would
be the standard deviation.
Why is that valuable?
Because that tells you
something about how badly things
are dispersed,
how much variation
there is in this measurement.
And so if it says, if I can
minimize this expression,
that's great because
it not only will
find what I hope
is the best fit,
but it's going to minimize the
variance between what I predict
and what I measure, which
makes intuitive sense.
That's exactly the thing
I would like to minimize.
This was built on
the assumption that I
had a line that I
thought was a good fit,
and this lets me measure
how good a fit I have.
But I still have to
do a little bit more.
I have to now figure
out, OK, how do
I find the best-fitting line?
And for that, we need to come up
with a minimization technique.
So to minimize this
objective function,
I want to find the curve
for the predicted values--
this thing here--
some way of representing
that that leads
to the best possible solution.
And I'm going to make
a simple assumption.
I'm going to assume
that my model for this
predicted curve--
I've been using the
example of a line,
but we're going to say curve--
is a polynomial.
It's a polynomial
and one variable.
The one variable is what are
the x values of the samples.
And I'm going to assume that
the curve is a polynomial.
In the simplest case, it's a
line in case order, and two,
it's going to be a parabola.
And I'm going to use a technique
called linear regression
to find the polynomial that best
fits the data, that minimizes
that objective function.
Quick aside, just to remind
you, I'm sure you remember,
so polynomial--
polynomials, either the value
is zero, which is really boring,
or it is a finite
sum of non-zero terms
that all have the form
c times x to the p.
C is a constant, a real number.
P is a power, a
non-negative integer.
And this is basically-- x
is the free variable that's
going to capture this.
So easy way to say
it is a line would
be represented as a degree
one polynomial ax plus b.
A parabola is a
second-degree polynomial,
ax squared plus bx plus c.
And we can go up to
higher order terms.
We're going to refer to the
degree of the polynomial
as the largest degree of
any term in that polynomial.
So again, degree one, linear
degree two, quadratic.
Now how do I use that?
Well, here's the basic idea.
Let's take a simple example.
Let's assume I'm still
just trying to fit a line.
So my assumption is I
want to find a degree one
polynomial, y equals ax plus
b, as our model of the day.
That means for every sample,
I'm going to plug in x,
and if I know a and b, it
gives me the predicted value.
I've already seen
that's going to give me
a good measure of the
closeness of the fit.
And the question is,
how do I find a and b.
My goal is find a
and b such that when
we use this polynomial to
compute those y values,
that sum squared
difference is minimized.
So the sum squared difference
is my measure of fit.
All I have to do
is find a and b.
And that's where linear
regression comes in,
and I want to just give you
a visualization of this.
If a line is described
by ax plus b,
then I can represent
every possible line
in a two-dimensional space.
One axis is possible
values for a.
The other axis is
possible values for b.
So if you think about it, I
take any point in that space.
It gives me an a and a B value.
That describes a line.
Why should you care about that?
Because I can put a
two-dimensional surface
over that space.
In other words, for every a
and b, that gives me a line,
and I could, therefore,
compute this function,
given the observed values
and the predicted values,
and it would give
me a value, which
is the height of the
surface in that space.
If you're with me with
the visualization,
why is that nice?
Because linear regression
gives me a very easy way
to find the lowest
point on that surface,
which is exactly
the solution I want,
because that's the
best fitting line.
And it's called
linear regression
not because we're
solving for a line,
but because of how
you do that solution.
If you think of this as being--
take a marble on this
two-dimensional surface,
you want to place
the marble on it,
you want to let it
run down to the lowest
point in the surface.
And oh, yeah, I promised you
why do we use sum squares,
because if we used the
sum of the squares,
that surface always
has only one minimum.
So it's not a really
funky, convoluted surface.
It has exactly one minimum.
It's called linear
regression because the way
to find it is to start at
some point and walk downhill.
I linearly regress or walk
downhill along the gradient
some distance, measure
the new gradient,
and do that until I
get down to the lowest
point in the surface.
Could you write code to do it?
Sure.
Are we going to
ask you to do it?
No, because fortunately--
I was hoping to get
a cheer out of that.
Too bad.
OK, maybe we will ask
you to do it on the exam.
What the hell.
You could do it.
In fact, you've seen
a version of this.
The typical algorithm
for doing it
is very similar
to Newton's method
that we used way back in
the beginning of 60001
when we found square roots.
You could write that
kind of a solution,
but the good news is
that the nice people who
wrote Python, or
particularly PyLab,
have given you code to do it.
And we're going to
take advantage of it.
So in PyLab there is a built-in
function called polyFit.
It takes a collection
of x values,
takes a collection
of equal length
of y values-- they need
to be the same length.
I'm going to assume
they're arrays.
And it takes an integer n,
which is the degree of fit,
that I want to apply.
And what polyFit
will do is it will
find the coefficients of a
polynomial of that degree that
provides the best
least squares fit.
So think of it as
polyFit walking along
that surface to find the best
a and b that will come back.
So if I give it a
value of n equals one,
it'll give me back the a and
b that gives me the best line.
If I get a value
of n equal two, it
gives me back a,
b, and c that would
fit an ax squared plus bx plus
c parabola to best fit the data.
And I could pick n to be
any non-negative integer,
and it would actually
come up with a good fit.
So let's use it.
I'm going to write a little
function called fitData.
The first part up here
just comes from plotData.
It's exactly the same thing.
I read in the data.
I convert them into arrays.
I convert this because I
want to get out the force.
I go ahead and plot it.
And then notice what I do,
I use polyFit right here
to take the inputted x values
and y values and a degree one,
and it's going to
give me back a tuple,
an a and a b that are
the best fit line.
Finds that point in the
space that best fits it.
Once I've got that, I could go
ahead and actually compute now
what are the estimated
or predicted values.
The line's going
to tell me what I
should have seen
as those values,
and I'm going to
do the same thing.
I'm going to take x values,
convert it into array,
multiply it by a, which says
every entry in the array
is scaled by a.
Add b to every entry.
So I'm just computing ax
plus b for all possible x's.
And that then gives me an
estimated set of y values,
and I can plot those out.
I'm cheating here.
Sorry.
I'm misdirecting you.
I never cheat.
I actually don't need to do
the conversion to an array
there because I did it up here.
But because I've borrowed
this from plot lab,
I wanted to show you
that I can redundantly
do it here to remind you
that I want to convert it
into array to make sure I can
do that kind of algebra on it.
The last thing I could
do is say even if I can--
once I show you the
fit of this line,
I also want to get out
the spring constant.
Now, the slope of this
line is difference in force
over difference in distance.
The spring constant
is the opposite of it.
So I could simply take the
slope of the line, which
is a, invert it, and that
gives me the spring constant.
So let's see what happens
if we actually run this.
So I'm going to go
over to my code,
hoping that it works properly.
Here's my Python.
I've loaded this in.
I'm going to run it.
And there you go.
Fits a line, and it
prints out the value
of a, which is about
0.46, and the value of b.
And if I go back
and look at this,
there we go, spring constant
is about 21 and a half,
which is about the
reciprocal of 0.046
if you can figure that out.
And you can see,
it's not a bad fit
to a line through that data.
Again, there's still something
funky going on over here
that we're going
to come back to.
But it's a pretty
good fit to the data.
Great.
So now I've got a fit.
I'm going to show you
a variation of this
that we're going
to use in a second.
I could do the same thing, but
after I've done polyFit here,
I'm going to use another
built-in function called
polyval.
It's going to take
a polynomial, which
is captured by that model of
the thing that I returned,
and I'm going to show
you the difference again.
Back sure we returned
this as a tuple.
Since it's coming
back as a tuple,
I can give it a name model.
Polyval will take that
tuple plus the x values
and do the same thing.
It will give me back an
array of predicted values.
But the nice thing here is that
this model could be a line.
It could be a parabola.
It could be a quartic.
It could be a quintic.
It could be any
order polynomial.
If you like the
abstraction here-- which
we're going to see
in a little bit,
that it allows me
to use the same code
for different orders of model.
And if I ran this, it would
do exactly the same thing.
I'm going to come back to
thinking about what's going
on in that spring in a second.
But I want to show
you another example.
So here's another set of data.
In a little bit,
I'll show you where
that mystery data came from.
But here's another set of
data that I've plotted out.
I could run the same thing.
I could run exactly the same
code and fit a line to it.
And if I do it, I get that.
What do you think?
Good fit?
Show of hands, how many people
like this fit to the data?
Show of hands, how
many people don't
like this fit to the data?
Show of hands, how
many hope that I'll
stop asking you questions?
Don't put your hands up.
Yeah, thank you.
I know.
Too bad.
It's a lousy fit.
And you kind of know it, right.
It's clear that
this doesn't look
like it's coming
from a line, or if it
is, it's a really noisy line.
So let's think about this.
What if I were to try
a higher order degree.
Let's change the one to a two.
So I'm going to come
back to it in a second.
I've changed the one to a two.
That says I'm still
using the polynomial fit,
but now I'm going to ask what's
the best fitting parabola, ax
squared plus bx plus c.
Simple change.
Because I was using polyval,
exactly the same code
will work.
It's going to do the fit to it.
This is, by the way, still an
example of linear regression.
So think of what I'm doing now.
I have a
three-dimensional space.
One axis is a values.
Second axis is b values.
Third axis is c values.
Any point in that space
describes a parabola,
and every point in
that space describes
every possible parabola.
And now you've got to twist
your head a little bit.
Put a four-dimensional
surface on
that three-dimensional basis,
where the point in that surface
is the value of that
objective function.
Play the same game.
And you can.
It's just a
higher-dimensional thing.
So you're, again, going
to walk down the gradient
to find the solution,
and be glad you don't
have to write this code
because PyLab will do it
for you freely.
But it's still an example of
regression, which is great.
And if we do that,
we get that fit.
Actually just to show you
that, I'm going to run it,
but it will do exactly
the same thing.
If I go over to Python--
wherever I have it here--
I'm going to change
that order of the model.
Oops, it went a
little too far for me.
Sorry about that.
Let me go back
and do this again.
There's the first one, and
there's the second one.
So I could fit
different models to it.
Quadratic clearly looks
like it's a better fit.
I hope you'll agree.
So how do I decide
which one's better
other than eyeballing it?
And then if I could
fit a quadratic to it,
what about other
orders of polynomials?
Maybe there's an even
better fit out there.
So how do I figure out what's
the best way to do the fit?
And that leads to the second
big thing for this lecture.
How good are these fits?
What's the first big thing?
The idea of linear
regression, a way of finding
fits of curves to data.
But now I've got to
decide how good are these.
And I could ask this
question two ways.
One is just relative
to each other,
how do I measure which one's
better other than looking
at it by eye?
And then the second part of
it is in an absolute sense,
how do I know where
the best solution is?
Is quadratic the
best I could do?
Or should I be
doing something else
to try and figure out a
better solution, a better
fit to the data?
The relative fit.
What are we doing here?
We're fitting a curve,
which is a function
of the independent variable
to the dependent variable.
What does it mean by that?
I've got a set of x values.
I'm trying to predict what
the y values should be,
the displacement should be.
I want to get a
good fit to that.
The idea is that given
an independent value,
it gives me an estimate
of what it should be,
and I really want to know
which fit provides the better
estimates.
And since I was simply
minimizing mean squared error,
average square error,
an obvious thing to do
is just to use the goodness of
fit by looking at that error.
Why not just measure
where am I on that surface
and see which one does better?
Or actually it would
be two surfaces,
one for a linear fit,
one for a quadratic one.
We'll do what we always do.
Let's write a
little bit of code.
I can write something
that's going
to get the average,
mean squared error.
Takes in a set of data points,
a set of predicted values,
simply measures the
difference between them,
squares them, adds them
all up in a little loop
here and returns that divided
by the number of samples I have.
So it gives me the
average squared error.
And I could do it for
that first model I built,
which was for a
linear fit, and I
could do it for the
second model I built,
which is a quadratic fit.
And if I run it, I
get those values.
Looks pretty good.
You knew by eye that the
quadratic was a better fit.
And look, this says it's
about six times better,
that the residual error
is six times smaller
with the quadratic model
than it is the linear model.
But with that, I still
have a problem, which is--
OK, so it's useful for
comparing two models.
But is 1524 a good number?
Certainly better than
9,000-something or other.
But how do I know that
1524 is a good number?
How do I know there isn't a
better fit out there somewhere?
Well, good news is we're going
to be able to measure that.
It's hard to know because
there's no bound on the values.
And more importantly, this
is not scale independent.
What do I mean by that?
If I take all of the values and
multiply them by some factor,
I would still fit the
same models to them.
They would just scale.
But that measure would
increase by that amount.
So I could make the
error as big or as small
as I want by just changing
the size of the values.
That doesn't make any sense.
I'd like a way to
measure goodness of fit
that is scale independent
and that tells me
for any fit how close
it comes to being
the perfect fit to the data.
And so for that, we're
going to use something
called the coefficient
of determination
written as r squared.
So let me show you what
this does, and then we're
going to use it.
The y's are measured values.
Those are my samples I
got from my experiment.
The p's are the
predicted values.
That is, for this
curve, here's what I
predict those values should be.
So the top here is
basically measuring
as we saw before the sum
squared error in those pieces.
Mu down here is the average, or
mean, of the measured values.
It's the average of the y's.
So what I've got here
is in the numerator--
this is basically the error
in the estimates from my curve
fit.
And in the denominator I've
got the amount of variation
in the data itself.
This is telling me how much does
the data change from just being
a constant value, and this
is telling me how much
do my errors vary around it.
That ratio is scale independent
because it's a ratio.
So even if I increase
all of the values
by some amount, that's
going to divide out,
which is kind of nice.
So I could compute
that, and there it is.
R squared is, again,
that expression.
I'll take in a set
of observed values,
a set of predicted values,
and I'll measure the error--
again, these are arrays.
So I'm going to take the
difference between the arrays.
That's going to give me
piecewise or pairwise
that difference.
I'll square it.
That's going to give me at
every point in the array
the square of that distance.
And then because
it's an array, I
can just use the built-in sum
function to add them all up.
So this is going
to give me the--
if you like, the
values up there.
And then I'm going to
play a little trick.
I'm going to compute
the mean error, which
is that thing divided by
the number of observations.
Why would I do that?
Well, because then I can
compute this really simply.
I could write a little
loop to compute it.
But in fact, I've already
said what is that?
If I take that sum and divide
it by the number of samples,
that's the variance.
So that's really nice.
Right here I can
say, get the variance
using the non-p version
of the observed data.
And because that has
associated with it division
by the number of
samples, the ratio
of the mean error
to the variance
is exactly the same as
the ratio of that to that.
Little trick.
It lets me save doing a
little bit of computation.
So I can compute
r squared values.
So what does r squared
actually tell us?
What we're doing is we're
trying to compare the estimation
errors, the top part,
with the variability
in the original values,
the bottom part.
So r squared, as you're
going to see there,
it's intended to
capture what portion
of the variability in the data
is accounted for by my model.
My model's a really good fit.
It should account for
almost all of that data.
So what we see then is if we do
a fit with a linear regression,
r squared is always going
to be between zero and one.
And I want to just
show you some examples.
If r squared is equal
to one, this is great.
It says the model explains all
of the variability in the data.
And you can see it
if we go back here.
How do we make r
squared equal to one?
We need this to be
zero, which says
that the variability in
the data is perfectly
predicted by my model.
Every point lies
exactly along the curve.
That's great.
Second option at
the other extreme
is if r squared
is equal to zero,
you basically got bupkis, which
is a well-known technical term,
meaning there's no relationship
between the values predicted
by the model and
the actual data.
That basically says that
all of the variability
here is exactly the same as all
the variability in the data.
The model doesn't
capture anything,
and it's making this one, which
is making the whole thing zero.
And then in between an r
squared of about a half
says you're capturing
about half the variability.
So what you would
like is a system
in which your fit is as close
to an r squared value of one
as possible because
it says my model is
capturing all the variability
in the data really well.
So two functions that
will do this for us.
We're going to come back to
these in the next lecture.
The first one called
generate fits, or genFits,
will take a set of x
values, a set of y values,
and a list or a
tuple of degrees,
and these will be
the different degrees
of models I'd like to fit.
I could just give it one.
I could give it two.
I could give a 1, 2,
4, 8, 16, whatever.
And I'll just run
through a little loop
here where I'm going to
build up a set of models
for each degree--
or d in degrees.
I'll do the fit exactly
as I had before.
It's going to return
a model, which
is a tuple of coefficients.
And I'm going to store that
in models and then return it.
And then I'm going to use
that, because in testFits I
will take the models
that come from genFits,
I'll take the set of
degrees that I also passed
in there as well as the values.
I'll plot them
out, and then I'll
simply run through each of
the models and generate a fit,
compute the r squared value,
plot it, and then print out
some data.
With that in mind, let's see
what happens if we run this.
So I'm going to take,
again, that example
of that data that
I started with,
assuming I picked the right
one here, which I think
is this one.
I'm going to do a fit with
a degree one and a degree
two curve.
So I'm going to
fit the best line.
I'm going to fit the best
quadratic, the best parabola,
and I want to see how
well that comes out.
So I do that.
I got some data there.
Looks good.
And what does the data tell me?
Data says, oh, cool--
I know you don't
believe it, but it
is because notice
what it says, it
says the r squared value
for the line is horrible.
It accounts for less
than 0.05% of the data.
You could say, OK,
I can see that.
I look at it.
It does a lousy job.
On the other hand, the
quadratic is really pretty good.
It's accounting for about 84%
of the variability in the data.
This is a nice high value.
It's not one, but it's
a nice high value.
So this is now
reinforcing what I already
knew, but in a nice way.
It's telling me that that
r squared value tells me
that the quadratic is a much
better fit than the linear fit
was.
But then you say
maybe, wait a minute.
I could have done this by just
comparing the fits themselves.
I already saw that.
Part of my goal is how
do I know if I've got
the best fit possible or not.
So I'm going to
do the same thing,
but now I'm going to run it
with another set of degrees.
I'm going to go over here.
I'm going to take
exactly the same code.
But let's try it
with a quadratic,
with a quartic, an order
eight, and an order 16 fit.
So I'm going to take
different size polynomials.
As a quick aside,
this is why I want
to use the PyLab kind
of code because now I'm
simply optimizing over
a 16-dimensional space.
Every point in that
16-dimensional space
defines a 16th-degree
polynomial.
And I can still use
linear regression,
meaning walking
down the gradient,
to find the best solution.
I'm going to run this.
And I get out a set of values.
Looks good.
And let's go look at them.
Here is the r squared value
for quadratic, about 84%.
Degree four does a
little bit better.
Degree eight does a
But wow, look at
that, degree 16--
16th order polynomial
does a really good job,
accounts for almost 97% of
the variability in the data.
That sounds great.
Now, to quote something
that your parents probably
said to you when you were much
younger, just because something
looks good doesn't
mean we should do it.
And in fact, just because
this has a really high r
squared value doesn't mean
that we want to use the order
16th polynomial.
And I will wonderfully leave
you waiting in suspense
because we're going to answer
that question next Monday.
And with that, I'll let you
out a few minutes early.
Have a great Thanksgiving break.